I'm very excited about this particular
seminar in our main series we've one of
the earliest talks we had I think in the
very first year of our salt series we
had rusty Schweickart who is one of the
cofounders of the b612 foundation with
Edie Lu talking about the asteroid
threat to earth and then later we had
Edie in the series and this is going to
be an interesting update because a lot
has evolved in since then and and so
he's gonna be giving us a good update
and I as somebody who people in the
press often ask about the long-term
future of Earth you know they they are
always asking about various existential
threats and and so they're like you know
what about climate change and what about
AI and I and I'm and I'm always kind of
baffled that they think that these are
actually existential threats I mean
they're definitely threats and they
might change the way the way of life on
earth the carrying capacity of Earth but
there are very few truly existential
threats and obviously asteroid impact is
truly one of them we know based on on
history that that's the case and so the
idea that the humanity would create a
space program and the first thing we did
was you know race to a little rock that
we know wasn't going to crash into Earth
the moon rather than actually solve this
problem was always very confusing to me
because we know it's the one that that
couldn't actually wipe out us whole
species and so the rest of it to me
everything else that we do on earth
besides this project is basically
rearranging the chairs on the Titanic to
stop it from sinking
so here tonight is that Lou to tell us
how to rearrange the chairs to actually
help us thank you
Thanks
it's a pleasure to be here at the long
now I just want to thank long now for
being such good friends of ours I think
we all have a common interest in
long-term thinking and preventing
ourselves from going away the dinosaurs
but long I've always admired the
foundation for the things you do and the
way you go about thinking about problems
and so it's kind of neat to get to give
a talk here so I want to talk about a
couple of things you know saving the
earth mapping the solar system you know
the bigger picture so let's get started
so that's me that's the title I just
thought I'd start with a little bit of a
show-and-tell this is a picture that I
took from my old office window onboard
the space station and if anybody's
really good at geography you might
recognize that that is north and this is
the Great Lakes you can see Ontario Erie
etc Chicago is wait just off the screen
there and hopefully we've circled in in
a little white circle there location of
Sudbury Ontario it's an interesting
location because it is the location of
some of the richest iron and nickel
mines on earth and it is actually where
one of the original Dow 30 companies was
founded income which was international
nickel company I think it was what the
actual abbreviation is for and to this
day it is still one of the biggest
sources of iron and nickel on earth and
the reason it is is because about 100
million years ago a very large asteroid
landed there love iron and nickel and so
actually you know it ends up affecting
the global economy again being an
original dow member you know 100 million
years later who would have thunk it huh
I'm gonna fast forward to February of
2013 this is the Russian city of
Chelyabinsk and this was caught on a
dashcam video
in Chelyabinsk early in the morning that
comes flashing across the sky and it was
a much smaller rock 19 metres across so
you know this building here is probably
I'm gonna guess 1213 meters across maybe
a little bit more so it's not that much
larger than this building but it was
moving at about Mach 75 or so something
like that unlike this building and it
exploded in midair now luckily it wasn't
actually that close to the city this
thing is actually about 40 kilometers
outside the city and heading away from
it and and I'm sure all of you know from
your days studying hypersonic shock
waves that the shock waves move in the
forward direction and therefore the the
main part of the shock wave went over
the city missing it by about 40
kilometers very lucky because the edges
of that shock wave did blow out every
window in the city collapsed seven
buildings and sent 1,500 people to the
hospital that's from the fringes of that
shock wave now this is a small asteroid
again think of flying interval right
interval bar but these things are
actually not that uncommon so these
smaller ones like this hit earth every
few decades
anybody here see the news the other day
they just released it although some of
us had known about a little while but in
December there was an explosion oh by
the way I should mention did this
explosion was about 30 times the size of
the bomb dropped over Hiroshima very
good sized explosion in December there
was a 170 kiloton explosion or about ten
times the size of the bomb dropped over
Hiroshima over the Bering Sea luckily
not a lot of population in the Bering
Sea but it happens right so in fact
there was no notice of this coming and
there was known as a lot of the one in
the Bering Strait obviously the one in
in Canada because there were no humans
alive at the time there was no notice of
but it actually isn't surprising that we
don't know about these things hitting
because 99% of the asteroids that we
care about that could cause destruction
on earth are actually uncharted unmapped
and so they would arrive with zero
notice
so that's our challenge actually is that
99% of the objects that we might care
about that actually affect life here on
earth are uncharted so what can we do
about it
and why might that be important so I'm
going to switch topic a little bit to
something bigger than saving the earth
because it turns out there is a bigger
picture than saving the earth and I want
to talk about I mean that's sort of like
the negative thing you're trying to
avoid right we want to avoid that but
there's got to be a positive thing
aspect to this and if I really think
about what the bigger picture is I think
that we are on the verge of opening up a
brand-new frontier and I'm gonna make
the argument that throughout human
history the opening of frontiers has
been enabled by mapping ok that mapping
has been crucial for in shorthand
notation and there will be quiz on this
for your greed and curiosity ok so as
you're at your next cocktail party you
could say fear greed and curiosity
that's why we map unknown regions
ok there'll be a quiz we can all repeat
this afterwards fear greed and curiosity
so let's look at the history of mapping
in five minutes this is a map that I
really like it is called the Cantino
planisphere it was found interestingly
enough on the wall of a butcher shop in
Modena Italy where it had languished it
had been created in the Year 1508 with a
lot of intrigue various spies have been
paid to steal information to create this
map and it was created by sort of
unknown characters probably in Portugal
and 1508 look at how detailed this was
it's actually amazing they you know you
can see parts of app you can see the
kingdoms in Africa you can see where
various animals and sea creatures lived
you can see the first compass roses for
navigation and so on and this is kind of
the effort that went into building this
to making this the amount of money paid
in bribes to steal these secrets was
extraordinary and the reason was is
because mapping was very important even
in those days why so why did the great
pair always want to have mapping they
were looking for trade routes
they were looking to defend their
territory and they were looking to see
what's out there fear greed and
curiosity in this case trade routes are
the degreed if you'd like where do we
put where are the lines of defense where
should we put our our forts that's the
fear part curiosity you know what what
else will help me find out there's a
whole big world out there it's fast
forward this is a map which is uh comes
from the rum see map center it's a
beautiful place done it some of you may
know about it sound Stanford and it is
one of the Lewis and Clark maps so if
you recall not any of you are alive back
then but when we purchased the United
States purchased the Louisiana Purchase
the very first thing Thomas Jefferson
did is he sent out Lewis and Clark on
what was called the Corps of Discovery
and he actually instructed them himself
in the artist celestial navigation so
that they could make maps because they
were sent out there to chart the New
Territories for three reasons
navigable points of Defense and to find
the samples of the flora and fauna for
your greed and cure asked and that is in
fact what Lewis and Clark did if you
ever get a chance to go down to Stanford
go check it out you can see originals
really cool so let's talk a little bit
about sort of non mapping not not sort
of classical mapping but it's the the
concept still is true in the 1990s as
the science of genetics really began to
advance one of the things we realized if
we really wanted to fully take advantage
of this new frontier of genomics was to
map the human genome why because we
wanted to know the relationships between
different genes and that would tell us
how to potentially protect ourselves
from diseases that's the fear part how
to develop medicines that could make a
lot of money there's a great part and
how we as humans evolved to become what
we are today because the record is in
the human genome curiosity it's the same
thing so this idea of opening up of new
frontiers and
bang they're integral and intimately
linked so what is the next great
frontier I think there's a bunch of them
but the one I want to concentrate on is
the great frontier of space and I want
to point something out to you this is a
chart from a Morgan Stanley report but
there's a similar report from Goldman
Sachs and I believe also a Merrill Lynch
one very similar it turns out that the
global space economy is actually already
350 billion dollars annually and it's
growing very very fast it comes in a
bunch of different areas and this is
sort of the money that's being spent on
companies doing things in space a lot of
this is communications for now but it's
growing very fast and they said if the
current rates continue we reach a
trillion dollars in you know not that
long at three at the at the current 7%
growth rate
now if you think about the you know you
all know that greatest force known to
man is the power of compound interest
right 7% growth rates means that this
will actually overtake the earths that
the terrestrial economy in about a
hundred years if you you know all things
being maintained and you never know but
it's not that long I think of China's
growth rates which are considered
extreme at 8% okay and think of how far
that that has changed in the last 20
years between China and call it the
United States or Europe which had has a
two percent growth rate small
percentages differences over 20 30 40
years
make an enormous difference and this has
that potential how else what its other
corroborating evidence for that this is
the number of spacecraft launched per
year where Green is private launches and
then the other countries Russia and us
and so on this is the number of launches
look at the last few years
look what's happened here and why is it
gone up so much it's green it's private
private launches in fact 18 is off the
top of this chart and 19 is expected to
be even higher so and if you look at the
plans for the upcoming launches it goes
way up above the chart at the top of
this chart two reasons cheaper launch
thank you SpaceX
Blue Origin and because of that their
effect on the big incumbents they're all
getting cheaper and - it's the
increasing capability to drop out by
small electronics the combination of
those two is making it easier to do
things in space so that private
investment can now do things that only
super powers could do 30 years ago
there are many space startups in the Bay
Area and it's taken off now will this
continue at this pace nobody knows you
know it's going to go up and down
there's gonna be recessions there's
going to be things like that but the
fact of the matter if you maintain a
high growth rate over 20 or 30 years
this dominates over the terrestrial
economy end of next century before the
end of next century which is interesting
right so when people say you know how
long will it be until the space economy
is of is critically important somebody I
would say it's already critically
important how long until it dominates
you may be in your kids lifetime it's
not that outlandish to think that
because the way these things always work
is everyone goes yeah it's insignificant
its insignificant until suddenly oh it
dominates and that can happen over a
period of 10 or 20 years as we've seen
for instance with China I just like this
picture I think it's an example of where
you know that that's you know Musk's
Roadster on its way out of Earth Earth's
gravity towards the asteroid belt so my
argument is that the opening of the
space frontier is going to be enabled by
the first comprehensive maps not that
it's the only thing that they're
obviously launched and all these other
things are going to be critically
important but a key aspect of this is
going to be mapping okay it's going to
be for the same three reasons for your
greed and curiosity so what do I do I'm
having let's give a picture of what the
solar system looks like let's talk about
the inner solar system and that's that's
where this this development is going to
take place the outer solar system is
many times further out but the inner
solar system really is the
earth if you see there's a Sun there
Mercury Venus Earth and Mars call that
the inner solar system and I will talk
about that that's really cool but this
is every single known asteroid okay so
you can see the asteroid belt and you
can see all these things are called
near-earth objects or near-earth
asteroids the ones in the middle those
the ones that can hit Earth those are
the ones actually are interesting for a
lot of reasons but this is remember 1%
of what's out there ok so if you'd like
the map looks like the the 1400s map of
the earth I knew where the big
continents were anything smaller than
that some of it we know most of it we
don't but those details matter
and the more commerce and the more trade
the more development the more people go
these places the finer the scale on what
you need to know need to have your map
right because I mean who would have
thought you know 20 or 30 years ago that
how important mapping would be to our
you know mapping on the scale of 1 meter
would be to our everyday lives
it the more you know these things feed
upon themselves the maps help develop
the the frontier the frontier demands
better maps and and and that kind of
thing is going to happen I believe so
let's talk about the fear greed and
curiosity maybe not in that order I
think I've mixed them up so let's talk
about curiosity or science if you want
to know the evolution of the earth that
record is written in the asteroids
because these are primordial things that
they're basically failed planetary
pieces and their locations in their
orbits tell you how the solar system
formed and as well as how the orbits of
the planets have changed over the years
and it they have so if you want to go
visit these bodies and take samples and
begin to understand the geology of these
bodies then you need to have a map of
where they all are right so here's a
cool picture I thought this is a
Japanese probe that's just about the
land on this asteroid this happened
about three weeks ago it dipped down and
then picked up
some samples there's a really cool
YouTube video on this and it's it's
sending a it's gonna shoot a little
projectile into it to try and create a
little tiny crater coming up here in the
next they want to say next week and
they'll bring those samples back to
earth but if you don't know where the
majority of these objects are you can't
visit them you have to know very
precisely where an object is we'll talk
a little bit more how that's even more
complicated because everything is moving
so it's not really where it is it's
where it's going to be so so green so if
indeed there is development throughout
the solar system and I believe there
will be then maps are going to be
important because a if you know if
people are gonna live in space where are
they going to get their materials from
they're gonna get them from you can get
them from planetary bodies the surface
of the earth and the moon or things like
that but you have to lift them out of
the gravity field and there's anybody
who knows that has ever seen a very
large rocket take off it it takes a lot
of energy to get things off the surface
of a planet and a lot of energy
basically equates to a lot of cost the
easiest place to get materials from is
from asteroids because they have very
low surface gravity and you can just
grab stuff also comes with complications
of operating there because sometimes
it's more convenient to have gravity
holding you in one spot I can say this
for sure and that when you're in space
it's if you're weightless it can
sometimes be a pain in the butt to tell
you the truth but
you didn't hear me say that um this was
all for shadowed by a guy named Jerry
O'Neill very influential guy in the late
60s early 70s who started talking about
colonies and space and making the
argument that if you look at the
continued growth of resource needs and
energy needs on earth you cannot have
exponential growth on planet Earth for
more than a couple more centuries at
anywheres near current rates and
therefore if there your society either
stagnates in size or it moves outwards
and that the amount of materials and
energy in space are many many many
orders of magnitude larger than what's
here on our little planet so he argued
that at some point it's inevitable and
you know maybe that that's a thousand
years from now but I that what I was
arguing earlier is that maybe that's
within fifty or a hundred years at which
people begin to move out but at some
point we surely have to and one of the
things we do know is that human
societies that have that stopped growing
actually tend to decay you know we we've
we've seen this you know the you know
some of the great empires Roman Empire
something ones that have stopped growing
for some reason have turned inwards you
know maybe this is all I has to do with
human nature and this is beyond the
scope but this talk but I think it's I
think it's important to have our
frontier for people to move into you
just want to show this this is an
interesting chart this is the Permian
Basin in Texas it's a it's a resource
claims map it's it's an oil claims map
these things are extraordinarily
important because when you have a map of
where the locations of resources are so
all these different color codes are
different who owns that claim and these
things are important because if you
cannot lay claim to finding some
resource and somebody else can just take
it from you
then you have no incentive to invest the
capital to extract any resources from it
all right so the United States managed
to you know develop a lot of things
because you people companies could lay
claim to things
and having a resource map is crucial to
that so this is an example the way
they're used on earth but if you think
out into the solar system if a company
goes to the effort of finding that there
is something usable on some location how
do they link claim to it what's the
proper way for is it a number in a table
or is it a map I really think the way
the way is going to be it's going to be
a map and last let's talk about the end
of the earth or preventing the end of
the earth
unfortunately these rocks whizzing
around the Sun that I showed you in that
early thing sometimes hit the earth the
most famous one to people is the one
that killed off the dinosaurs that was
65 million years ago it was an object
smaller than the Bay Area by quite a bit
roughly the size of San Francisco and
and it killed about 90 percent of the
species on earth by heating the entire
atmosphere of the earth over a period of
a few hours to about 500 degrees
sets fire to everything it's a really
bad day basic everything died or burns
off that day it's a really it's a fast
thing it's not it's not as people
picture where that it's drawn out over
decades it's not it's generally most of
those things died in day one on a much
smaller level this is June 30th 1908
this is the Siberian forests of Tunguska
there were there was an explosion of an
object about 40 meters across
so picture double the size of the
interval okay in diameter making it 2
cubed or 8 times larger and it took out
an area roughly the size of the San
Francisco Bay Area
so this had energy a few hundred not
quite a thousand times between 500 and a
thousand times the energy of the bomb
dropped over Hiroshima so if you overlay
the area of destruction on a this sort
of major cities you see that it wouldn't
be good for to get hit by one of these
and now let's everybody say together huh
what fraction of these have we
discovered one percent so ninety-nine
out of a hundred of them arrived
unannounced
now luckily most of the earth is
unpopulated but you know if it's not
your day well and as I like to say the
the you know the the way forward on this
isn't to rely on hope is your strategy
we can do something about it you know
and we're at that point where we can we
should so what do I mean by a space map
unlike the older maps which were
two-dimensional the map of space has got
to be inherently three-dimensional
there's there's a third dimension to it
and there's a fourth dimension to it
time because remember everything was
moving so you can't just say where is an
object you have to say where is an
object at what time and the speeds are
not slow like tectonic plates they are
extraordinarily fast in the range of 50
to a hundred thousand miles per hour for
almost all these objects okay but it
turns out people actually for a long
time been building maps if you'd like of
the solar system so an example is that
thing back there the orrery in fact
that's a map that is a model of the
solar system and if you really think
about what this thing this space map is
it is a three-dimensional depiction
where time is can be set as a slider for
instance where everything is moving and
that thing when you crank it up shows
the planets and and those were used you
know hundreds of years ago to for people
to understand how the planets moved
around the Sun and how their moons moved
around the planet and so on that was a
visual aid to understand in some sense
that you can make these things
anatomically accurate in that the
relative locations of the they're not
scale but the relative location the
directions are correct and what we want
to do is build this map or the solar
system so what does that mean in a
modern day and age well first off I need
to be in order to know where the
asteroids are now what I need to do is I
got built telescopes I need to observe
an asteroid and I need to watch it move
for some period of time so I can figure
out what its orbitals and then I need to
have math and I need to understand
orbital make
Nexen I can calculate the the trajectory
of that one particular asteroid and now
I really need to repeat by a million
times there's a million or so asteroids
that and I need to do that and I need to
update these things so the first thing
you need to building a really good map
at the solar system these telescopes
now this isn't that much different than
how we map the surface of the earth
you know we had spy satellites which
became commercial satellites looking
down at the earth and but the original
ones were built by governments and that
data was held secret and tightly held
eventually became open and eventually
became publicly available and a couple
of companies were able to take these
publicly available information and make
really good use of it different than the
way the CIA analyst and those types of
folks looked at things they built things
that were usable they built Google Earth
they're people mess that don't MapQuest
what we want to do is follow that same
tack we want to take data from these
telescopes and these are some
interesting telescopes the one up there
is one called pan-starrs it's in Hawaii
and it's on the top of Maui and it is
the current most powerful telescope for
finding tracking asteroids on earth the
one in the middle is one called the
large synoptic survey telescope it is a
it is going to be the world's largest
survey telescope for finding asteroids
and looking into the formation and
evolution of the universe that was that
is being built currently in Chile by the
National Science Foundation for about
700 million dollars and it becomes
operational in about two-and-a-half
years and so the that thing there is
about 50 times more powerful than this
one and so what's going to happen here
is that the publicly available datasets
remember this is paid for by the US
government it's going to explode there's
going to be an enormous number of new
discoveries now it's not going to find
all the asteroids we want to find but
it's going to do a heck of a lot better
than anything out there right now so
what it's means we're gonna have a lot
of data what are we going to do with it
are we preparing to deal with this data
how do we make that map out of this data
because really what this thing is
finding is not it's not producing a map
any more than Google Maps is the same as
a bunch of photographs of the earth
taken by spy satellites somebody had to
build a system that allows you to
navigate around and allows you to do
things like turn-by-turn directions
you know place my store here that sort
of stuff all those things are what made
Google Maps useful that's not been done
for the solar system for navigating to
asteroids for calculating what if an
asteroid might hit the earth if for
laying resource claims for doing
deep-space navigation all those things
are going to be services built on a map
so maps are changing from
two-dimensional to four-dimensional and
they're changing from static objects to
services and and if you think about what
this map is going to be it's going to be
assert it's gonna be is something that
exists in computers that people can
access and use and build off down in the
lower right it turns out that we believe
that there is ways to go beyond what
even this telescope can do and taking
advantage of very very rapid computer
graphics processing thank you to the
video game and movie industries billions
of dollars have been pumped into that
and cryptocurrency believe it or not
that investment has allowed us to do
graphics processing on a scale that was
and is it would have been unheard of
even ten years ago and we have shown
that if you have that you can take small
telescopes unlike this behemoth I mean
this thing is it's almost 30 feet across
that main mirror and shrink that down to
something about this big and rather than
taking short exposures you take very
very very long exposures that are
complicated with lots of asteroids
moving in all sorts of different
different directions that are all much
dimmer than just the background noise
and and pull all those asteroids out if
you have fast enough graphics processing
you basically you stack images for those
who know what that means and and you and
you check every possible combination and
if you can do 10 to the 13th or so
computations per second doable today
you can pull those asteroids out of the
noise and we've shown that this works on
a ground-based telescope and that means
that a space telescope could actually be
quite small for doing this very exciting
but anyhow the date is coming what do
you do with the data again you have to
build this you have to turn it into
something usable a date map is more than
just a pile of numbers it is a it is a
system thing Google Maps that allows you
to query it and get the information you
want and add things to it it's open it's
extensible others can add information
others you can extract information and
you have tools that allow you to do
things like zoom and go places and
calculate trajectories or in the case of
Google Maps turn-by-turn directions to
my house and that in fact is what we're
building so this is the beginnings of it
it's just it is a depiction of we're
only showing a hundred asteroids here
because if you show them all it becomes
a giant mess so you have to figure out
ways to only see the things you want so
you have to have filters in here too
that allow because you don't want to see
everything if there's a million
asteroids on there it's a it's a giant
mess one of the things that we are
working on is how do you see
three-dimensional things in flat you
know on a flat screen is it stuff on a
flat screen and how do you manipulate it
like it's say if I want to move some
object let's say if I move this object
from here to here or I wait from time
here some time to another time how do I
do that and that is something that that
perhaps and an augmented reality or a
virtual reality type thing maybe that's
the right solution for this sort of
thing or maybe at some point we'll have
we'll have better holographic projectors
other than the small ones which we have
available today but you know I can
picture in my head an augmented reality
the thing where someone could step into
a very large room and see those
asteroids I showed earlier on floating
throughout you know moving and I could
look at individual ones and where I want
to go and where I want to start from and
how I navigate between them and that
that could be the interface at some
point so that's what the map of the
solar system is going to be and that's
what we at the asteroid Institute part
of the 6/12 foundation are doing
so there are some of you who may
remember some years ago we set out to
say hey there was this big problem that
we need to find and track all these
asteroids and our first going in thing
was well we need to build a really big
telescope very expensive and that's what
we set out to do around that time a few
years later is when the National Science
Foundation said well we will build this
telescope you know for three-quarters of
a billion dollars and what we realize is
that means we didn't need to build that
telescope and maybe we should
concentrate on how you make use of this
data how you turn it into something
usable how we build that map for the you
know for the next hundred years and so
it's become in some sense largely a
computation of computer science /
astrophysics problem as opposed to a
build a very very very large expensive
telescope problem and it's it's changed
our thinking on things but it's been
quite a journey that so that's far and
so that's basically what we're up to and
when I say continued you know we need to
be ready here in the next year years
because there's an awful lot of data
coming down the pike in about two and a
half years the floodgates of that
telescope in Chile open up and there's
going to be about 50 times more
discoveries than we see each and every
currently that rates going up by about a
factor of 50 and we should be ready for
it so that is how I see this playing out
and just want to thank you for for
coming tonight and happy to answer any
question on anything
[Applause]
turn me on all right
and I should say we actually have as we
get reset here with some chairs that we
do have a larger online audience we're
experimenting with our stream being on a
broader platform it's on Facebook is our
Facebook thing working Facebook people
welcome face but everyone say welcome
Facebook all right so yes we do have
that audience and because of that and
because I got in trouble last time for
being having bad mic discipline with our
questions for the recording afterwards
so there's 50 of us here in the room but
over a thousand or actually I think now
close to 3,000 people listen to this
podcast for the so if you if you if you
do no one can hear your question and
then we cut your whole question and your
whole answer from that and so please do
that and if you do a follow up question
with no mic you also get cut so don't be
that person so it seems like we're all
here in this room but we're not there's
another few thousand people that are
gonna want to listen to this afterwards
so try and help and so yes short
questions we don't need your bio we just
need a very short concise question we'll
work with that
those are I think those are all the
things I got in trouble for last time
right all right can you I mean I know
that we've heard many times that
astronauts who go to space and look back
down on Earth are changed and I I can
only assume that the reason the b612
foundation said anyone no understand the
b612 reference little prince yes the
little planes please little prince up
here by the way it is if yes in case
that two astronauts into planetary
scientists found at the b612 but i
wanted to hear a little bit about your
personal story of how you what why this
matters to you aside from you
live on this planet when you when you
look at the earth and you look at the
moon which you get to do if you're up
that vantage point at the same time it's
kind of a neat view and you look at all
the craters on the moon hundreds of
thousands of craters craters on top of
craters
right and you look at the earth and you
go wait a second the earth gets hit more
than the moon does ok so the atmosphere
protects us from some of it plate
tectonics and the oceans they erase a
lot of them but the earth gets hit by
more and knowing a little bit of physics
a little bit of physics is a dangerous
thing but you say to yourself wow you
know the earth gets hit a lot and in
fact if you look at the kind of that you
know the sort of mass extinction sized
asteroids like the one that happened 65
million years ago I mean those have
happened hundreds of times on earth so
we have had multiple resets of life on
earth and it feels like maybe on our
watch it shouldn't happen again and
actually if you could help solve a
argument that Stuart brand and I have
been having Stuart's right sorry you
don't know which side he's on and so you
say that we've only mapped 1% but are
they is it really the is it now the
biggest 1 percent are we are their
extinction level event asteroids out
there at to a large extent at this point
that we have not mapped where are we
yeah it's I was oversimplifying in the
sense that there are big asteroids and
they're small asteroids and the bigger
ones are easy to spot they're bigger you
can spot them for further distance away
so the larger they are the greater the
chance that we've seen it so if you get
to the point where they're large enough
to wipe out human civilization we've
seen about 90 95 percent we think of
those okay and so that's pretty good
it doesn't mean that we've seen them all
now when you get down to the ones sort
of like call it 140 meters we're done in
this sort of 10 to 30 percent range and
and just for reference that's a hundred
Megaton explosion this is you know think
something a hundred times bigger than
what we saw in Tunguska so there we're
not doing as well by the time you got
down to that small and by the time you
get down to something
that would only destroy us like a major
city more in the one-percent range so
it's the bigger they are the easier they
are to see and I'm also really curious I
mean there's Tunguska chaplain chaplains
in Chelyabinsk the Bering Strait what
why do asteroids hit Russia so much they
do in fact know a lot of it is just land
mass yeah no I just flew over all of
Russia to Siberia and but it also is
very curious to me so I mean I get that
you take the train Russia is the biggest
country so it definitely is going to hit
there more but also is curious to me
that I've never heard of human record of
massive tsunamis created by asteroids
because you think with vastly more land
area well not on land area being water
area that we would have seen we would
have human record of massive tsunamis
created there there are human right
there are massive tsunamis there are
records of those all around the world
and you know this by finding things like
seashells up sides of mountains and so
on problem is you don't know whether
that was an earthquake or what caused it
right some cases that in some few cases
you can say oh this was due to this
event because we have very good timing
like there was one in Japan and I want
to say 1600 something and they know the
earthquake because of tree rings in Yap
but the the fact of the matter is you
you can't tell where it can we don't
know in antiquity if there's earthquakes
are absolute yes quakes are more calm
yeah and so you're gonna be raise your
hand if you do have a question I know
there's probably no questions in the
audience but he'll he'll be passing that
out to you I I'm gonna still take some
of mine because I have a bunch here yo
or the microphone the actually I think I
actually go oh yeah I mean the other
question I have is so we had what was
the name it was more of a comet than an
asteroid that
muah-muah oh and that's I mean that's a
stunningly large object to have moved
through our atmosphere and I realized it
came out of the ecliptic plane more like
a comet which I guess did you should can
you distinguish what comets are versus
asteroids and and why they're possibly
more surprising then even crazier than
that but comets are things are generally
icy bodies that come from very far away
from the Sun coming shooting into the
middle angle back out sometimes
regularly like Halley's Comet asteroids
or things like that we showed going
around the Sun inside fairly regular
small orbits you know kind of in our
part of the neighborhood Oh Momo I was
very by the way it was it's a Hawaiian
name because it was discovered by genres
in Hawaii and this was discovered last
year it was a very interesting object
because it was moving really fast in
fact it was moving fast enough that we
knew that it was actually gonna fly
through the solar system ago out but if
it was flying through the solar system
that meant it came from outside the
solar system because it did it had way
too much energy to been pulled in by the
Sun's gravity could never the Sun could
not accelerate it to that speed that
means this was an extraterrestrial
visitor from some other star system and
that was clearly established but its
speed was just way too high what made it
even more interesting is I want and one
of our researchers at the asteroid
Institute Bryce Boland was intimately
involved with noticing this is they it
was so far away we couldn't actually get
a picture of it so you can't see the
actual thing but what you could see is
the brightness of it what they noticed
is that the brightness was varying it
was getting dimmer and then brighter
than dimmer than brighter and that's
because it it's not round right so if
you're looking at it sideways you know
you it looks bigger you know and then if
you're looking at an end on it looks
smaller and by the difference in
brightness between the brightest and the
dimmest part you could tell what the
fraction are how elongated it was right
because if it was a sphere it wouldn't
change it off if it it turns out this
thing is shaped like a needle it's ten
times longer than it
was wide and that's a really strange
looking object so you know there were a
lot of crazy things and British tabloid
newspapers came out but and I'm not
saying it was aliens it was aliens don't
don't put me on that no well it
definitely was alien of some it was non
solar-system yeah so it came in and went
it's on its way out of the solar system
right yeah that whole story I think
really struck me is something that came
through the inner solar system not the
outer solar system but the inner soul
came right past stuff it was a pretty
large object yeah good stuff we still it
we didn't even get a picture of it like
that's how bad our vision is in our own
inner solar system of objects moving
through it well I think it's amazing
that we saw it at all think that I would
like to you know if some major object
even if it was a spacecraft that that's
how crappy we would be at sea yeah well
we've got we've got a ways to go in
terms of our telescopes and they're
getting better like I said that large
synoptic survey telescope is they're
flipping the switch here coming up soon
and we think we can do even better than
eventually but we are really going to be
discovering these asteroids and tracking
them what do you do with that it's very
likely that objects like that having
whizzing by us and we just haven't been
seeing them quite possible yeah quite
puffs all right I'll let somebody else
ask a question so you were you in the
conversation before the talk you were
talking about having to be 10 minutes
ahead when you're flying a fast airplane
I mean you're thinking and so I'm
assuming that you in building into your
software to start digesting this data
are you building in smoke alarms and
alerts like that something's you found
something that's about to hit well what
would be that what would be the 10
minutes what's the time frame out you'd
be you know I should back it up and I
didn't mention this that if you find
something that's going to hit the earth
deflecting it is actually relatively
easy because if you find it many years
before it hits the earth say 10 20 years
before it's the earth remember the earth
is going to go around the Sun 10 or 20
times as well that object so these
things have a long ways to travel before
they hit and that means a tiny time
tiny change in their in their orbit will
keep it something from hitting the earth
you just slow the earth down a little
bit yes everybody's a great new Chinese
gonna be coming out of Malthus but for
those of you who took physics we all
jump at the same time we don't change
the velocity of the earth because we're
connected to it right you need an
external momentum so what do you
actually do sir yeah the boring answer
is to change the orbits of the asteroid
by a tiny amount and one of the things
that we had been urging since the
foundation of our the b612 foundation is
that we human beings ought to test that
technology because we know how to do it
and in fact NASA is now we're going to
do that test it's called the dart
mission again about 2022 I believe it is
we're just going to actually run a small
spacecraft into an asteroid and then
it's actually sufficient in mass
majority of cases to keep an asteroid
from hitting the earth provided you have
notice now right now I don't want to go
back now back to your question the you
know predicting that something is going
to hit requires you can't be able to
calculate you know orbits very very
accurately and know the uncertainties in
order to calculate you know what are the
chances that this thing hits and I don't
want to give the impression that we're
the only ones doing there are other
people that think of you know they
calculate these things they put these
things in big tables okay but think of
what the difference is between Google
Maps and if somebody listed for you
every restaurant in New York City in a
big table what's the difference and why
is why was Google Maps so important to
commerce do two things like lyft and
uber they all started by using Google
Maps Yelp Airbnb because they didn't the
the visual mapping part the underlying
machinery was built for them and they
could just build on top of it and so
what we want to do is allow people to
build navigation tools for the solar
system without having to do all the
heavy lifting because 99.99% of the
calculation is exactly the same it can
happen in the background and so we want
to provide that as a service well that's
a great lead-in to a couple of the
questions that came in online beamed
into my head
the are you the alien yes they talked to
me the so you talked to a little bit
about the these massive ground-based
telescopes as well as some space-based
ones but as there's still a role for
small citizen science and telescopes and
in a related question is what is the
other citizen science elements like that
as related to something like SETI at
home where computation some of this
massive computation might be distributed
for people to get involved well I think
it is much of the backend of a map like
this isn't something that the citizen
it's not amenable to being broken up
into hundreds of thousands of little
small things but where the citizens can
come in is when you give them tools to
do more creative applications based off
of it so think of the you know hundreds
of thousands of applications built on
Apple maps or Google Maps or MapQuest
right that's where the creativity is
going to be come in but frankly the you
know the massive size databases that
we're talking about aren't things that
are going to be stored on somebody's
home computer as of right now those are
things that are going to be in the cloud
they're so big there and you need so
much computational power to pull that
things out but you can produce something
like that right so if I wanted to draw a
map of you know how to get from my house
here you know driving all the way to
Toronto Canada right how could I have
done that in 1990 you know now it took
me 30 seconds I'll plot it out and up I
hit print right or if I wanted to do a
map of like you know where are all the
coffee shops in you know Gary Indiana I
could do that right or you know somebody
in Karianna
Indiana is more likely to do that but
those are the type of applications that
eventually going to be needed I predict
if when there is a thriving space
economy any I don't think that's 100
years right now and what about small
telescopes I mean we still it still
seems like you know we we find out about
certain objects are named after actually
fairly
small as you know home-based astronomy
efforts is that is that gonna still be
happening it's at a limited level or is
it gonna be more these massive
telescopes and it's gonna be more of the
master telescopes because the massive
telescope is gonna be so much more
sensitive where the small telescopes can
become important is that sometimes when
you see an asteroid it's because it's
coming past the earth very close and
it's moving quickly and it's gonna go
away within a week or so and it won't be
visible by anyone but you want to get as
many observations as possible during
that week when it's visible and the more
telescopes that can be pointed at it
these are called follow-on observations
where somebody says we've seen one
here's where it roughly is and they go
find it and there are small telescopes
they're operated by amateurs around the
world and they're very important for
that but they don't there won't be as
good at the discovery aspect yes we have
any more questions right here the chili
beans asteroid apparently came out of
the Sun and as I understand it asked
telescopes on earth contact should be
pointed at the Sun so one of the b612
things was to put a you know a telescope
in space the interior orbit to the earth
in order to see those those asteroids -
is that still something you're trying to
do is there and well that I should
correct you a little bit in that the
reason you wanted to put the telescope
in wasn't because you were going to
catch things when they were looking at
them at the Sun remember you were gonna
find them decades before they hit many
after many many many orbits later before
they hit okay what that gives you by
moving inwards is is I you discover more
asteroids more frequently because you're
you're further inwards I can see it I
could see objects had greater percentage
of the time so it wasn't that because an
asteroid that's going to hit the earth
at some point has to have in its orbit
it has to go at least as far away from
the Sun as the earth otherwise it can't
hit the hit the earth right so at some
point they'll always cross Earth's orbit
if they're gonna hit Earth and so
was it the case you mentioned that they
it came out of the Sun I think direction
that means yeah that means on its last
approach it was coming that way now if
it hadn't hurt there would have flown
past it and go on outside and gone the
other way right so you will you'll see
it on the other side so remember you got
to get out of your mind the picture that
I'm just spotting it before it hits the
earth again I'm gonna spot this thing
early I'm gonna spot it a bunch of times
I'm gonna calculate it in orbit and know
it doesn't matter if it's coming in from
the other so what you're saying is it's
gonna cross Earth's path many many times
before the earth happens to be in the
way yeah they'll cross the orbit of
Earth the earth may not be there at that
point but it'll cross the orbit of the
earth and I think that's actually a
crucial thing that we're talking about
is that you know you're talking about
creating you know Google Maps for for
asteroid objects but what you're also
talking about is creating a not a
three-dimensional map but a four
dimensional map that this is that you're
it that works backwards and forwards in
time by it that's right actually a
decade so yeah you should be able to go
backwards just you know to say hold
where was that object before maybe I'm
interested in it for some reason
thank you yeah thanks for the talk in a
prior lecture you gave at the Marine
Memorial here you talked about the
foundation building satellites
much more accurate yeah the reason for
that is just because you you you know
looking away from the Sun you get the
background sky the is dimmer and that
means I can see dimmer asteroids so
that's my telescopes work much better at
night because you're looking at what you
know thought the sky itself is less
bright in that direction and that that's
all it is and besides the ground-based
telescopes and maybe some of these
smaller telescopes are there any of the
like the Kepler like telescopes or any
of those that are going to help some of
the detection efforts Kepler Kepler like
well not Kepler because kept has been
shut down
but there's generation there is a
potential NASA telescope which they're
fighting to get funding for hopefully it
does it's called neo cam and it will
find a large number of asteroids too it
still will not be able to find the
smallest ones that we want to find but
the very numerous ones but it's going to
be in sort of the same category of
effectiveness as LSST and the
combination of those two is better than
one or the other and are there are some
things like the power radio telescopes
like Arecibo that can detect darker
objects better or is that an effort
that's still Arecibo for those who don't
know it is a giant radar built in a
valley in Puerto Rico and radar is great
for seeing things that are very large
and very close because the well the
secret to understanding radars is the
signal drops off is what's called one
over R squared the further you get away
from something to one over R is the
distance but the signal coming back also
drops off as one over R squared so
radars drop off as one over R to the
fourth which means you make something
twice as far as a way it becomes sixteen
times harder to see which means radar
doesn't work very well at all for small
objects it's it's really a horrible
solution for small objects other
questions oh yeah we have a mic in the
back is it can you hear me yes and if
you sorry just to interrupt if you do
have a question between questions keep
your hand up and get his attention so
that he knows to come to you there yeah
so first of all thanks so much
the question is summary between fear and
curiosity and that's if I understand it
correctly there was no residue or
anything left at the Tunguska impact
site is that correct so if that's the
case then my question is how big does
something have to be to leave something
behind does that make sense yeah the
question is was there residue left at
the Tunguska site well the first thing
you notice is that the first expeditions
to that site were more than a decade
later I want to say almost 20 years
later before they managed to get to that
site that's how remote it was so the
chances of finding any residue at that
point you know with harsh winters and
melting of snow and you know repeat and
rinse and repeat are pretty small so we
I don't think they no one really
expected to find you know fresh debris
like you could it had had someone been
able to get to it right away
so the fact that that there isn't much
you know is actually not surprising at
all but but also in general these things
break up before they hit yeah the the
the asteroid at Tunguska did break up in
the atmosphere and explode in the
atmosphere which things of that size
tend to do the bigger if you get bigger
than that they'll hit the ground around
that's around the transition size at
which you'll likely to have an air
explosion and but just know that an air
explosion can be just as damaging if not
more damaging than a ground explosion
one of the sort of interesting I don't
know if interesting is the right word
but McCobb things is that if you want to
maximize damage from a nuclear weapon
you explode it in the air because it's
the shockwave that destroys things and a
question from online are there are there
any profit business business models for
your solar system map that you can see
right now I mean I know that we have all
these private space efforts and you
mentioned I think a little bit about
potential using of these the material
for offworld uses but can you elaborate
a little bit on the economics of that
someday when the it's a chicken and egg
thing right when the economy develops
out there such a thing is guaranteed to
be valuable the question is when is that
going to happen so while there may be
profitable things is it investable I
don't know because investable means I
have a timeline on which I expect to
return and if you don't know so what are
the kinds of organizations that can
invest when you don't know when the
return is so venture capital funds not
so much they they owe it to their
limited partners to return money within
a certain period of time
governments yes in WC Fund yeah
individual individuals belong a VC fund
just started right now we heard it but
individuals can because often they have
different both motivations as well as
timescales they may be thinking oh you
know this is the way I'm gonna be
remembered someday or just you know our
families can be remembered or something
like that and it isn't they're not doing
it because I owe to my limited partners
or return in five years I suspect it
costs I mean can you say what does a
pound of water cost in low-earth orbit
right now a good number right now is to
put a kilogram of anything into low
Earth orbit is depending upon how much
you've you launched it at a time in the
range of a thousand dollars thousand
dollars and so at some point you need to
make mining an asteroid for water or
some other resource that's used in orbit
or in some other way in space get to
that thousand dollars a kilogram I will
bet you that someday when there are
humans out there you know extensive
activity in space that they will have
uses for a map that we have we would
just never imagine right now any more
than I can imagine in 1950 or something
anybody would have thought wow people
will be you know that there would be
something like Yelp or Airbnb and who
would have thought of that so I think
you know the we're gonna be very bad
right now at guessing what the uses of
it are you know my argument is that
that mapping in general is is an enabler
of a lot of different things yeah and
actually that Brum zmapp archive is
great yeah sure I'll go down to the
Rumsey Maps all over those maps or edit
a tour for some tomorrow some reason at
great expense and great effort yeah we
have one more come over here yeah
lightning if we detect a comment as
opposed to an asteroid that is incoming
and appears to be likely to intercept
our position so comments are very very
different because they're moving it they
don't have the regular orbits around Sun
in a short period of time so you can
calculate their orbits they tend to come
in from far away where it's impossible
to see them there are 100 or thousand
times further than an asteroid and they
they suddenly start to come in towards
because something pushes them slightly
start to come in towards the Sun you
might have only a few months or so at a
much higher speed they're much larger in
almost every way they're far far far
more difficult than asteroids luckily
they are far far far less numerous so I
think we yeah we would we would have a
hard time you know they are a hundred
times a thousand times ten thousand
times less numerous what's the more than
a hundred times less numerous so I don't
have a solution and I think a lot of
people I'm getting a lot of questions
here from online I think you're hearing
them in the room as well as you know
what what are some of the needs that
that b612 has and that you are working
on right now that would be helpful so
here's my plea to the audience we need a
couple of good software engineers you
know we're building the the back end of
this cloud based system that analyzes
orbits and stores a database and moves
it around and when you query an object
it can calculate its orbit and present
that data in a useful manner and that's
really a couple of you know to three
software engineers and so what we need
is the means to you know we need to find
the right people
find the means to pay a couple of people
but that's really our need right now so
those of you who are working for some
real estate company creating their map
you could quit your job get paid way
less and you could create a four
dimensional star map for the future or
if there's any fabulously wealthy
software engineers that don't need to be
paid please come talk to us this week we
call those engineers post economic yeah
so close to economic and then I mean
what happened where's the hardware
coming from this are you creating some
of your own hardware to begin with you
know the map much of the data is gonna
show up at our doorstep right if we want
to go beyond that and I think we do then
we do have a project looking at building
these you know using rapid graphics
processing units a system to go up into
space and track the rest of the things
that LSST the LST telescope will miss
and for that we'll we'll need some
engineers to I think we're a little
further away from that right now we have
again a ground-based version running but
what our challenge is at the moment is
getting these graphics processors units
to run in space with this high radiation
causes bit flips it causes things to
crash that's why they don't typically
fly commercial electronics in space or
it doesn't work as well we think we can
solve that and we're actually hoping to
start it on that very very soon
but there might be hardware engineers
too that we might need in a year or so
but I think it already you're out on
that space-hardened video game graphics
cards exactly right yes well I want to
thank you very much for working a on
this project when our governments
clearly don't really work on their
buying that LSST telescope yeah well big
6-12 has been the forefront of this for
so long and i appreciate it so much and
i think the rest of civilization does as
well and i want to i want to give you a
challenge coin from the interval
please give him a round of applause
tonight can I came here much can I turn
this in for a software engineer yeah
those are good for one software
engineers spend it wisely can I have
another one next stop okay great
tomorrow thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]